le musée de l'histoire du perche fait la
part belle aux beaux-arts
une photo est adulé est portée au
firmament prise en 1858 elle immortalisa
paysage
une première pour l'époque désormais à
chef-d'oeuvre mondiale cette photo est
exceptionnelle elle est due aux
photographes
camille silvy qui est un pionnier de la
photographie c'est ainsi que son ami
nadar le qualifie et il va installer sa
chambre noire sur le pont de bois à
nogent le rotrou pour prendre cette
photographie et la manière dont ils
capturent ce paysage c'est exactement
comme un peintre qui brosse un paysage
cette photo c'est vraiment un
chef-d'oeuvre le mot n'est pas faible
mais quand camille silvy part en
angleterre y faire carrière pendant dix
ans le tout londres va se bousculer
et cette photo ainsi qu'une autre vue du
perche pourtant les temps gaïa vous
remporter un succès vif il restera
toujours un pionnier et un précurseur
dans son approche
un vrai peintre mais un photographe le
musée de l'histoire du perche est riche
de nombreuses aquarelles et le prêt de
400 objets aussi divers qu'inattendus
parmi ceux ci une matrice d'impression
dédié aux perches euros la race
percheronne est né à nogent le rotrou et
tire ses origines en fait des premières
croisades et les retrouve ramener les
premiers pur sang qui ont été croisées
avec la race locale et au fil des
siècles cette race a été amélioré et de
chevaux de guerre sont aussi devenus
chevaux de traits avec ma foi de deux
types chevaux de labour très travaux
dans les champs est également je vous
dis
nancy c'est de nogent le rotrou qu'est
parti ou presque le percheron pour
l'exploitation agricole des grandes
plaines américaines
le pays du soleil levant a lui aussi
fait du percheron
sinon un emblème du mois à cheval de
très grande renommée
les américains continuent toujours aller
à les utiliser là il s'agit de de
voltaire et ce cheval a été acheté par
un éleveur américain lors du premier
concours hippique percheron en france
d'ailleurs les américains étaient très
attendus au 19e siècle c'était une
véritable fête à nogent le rotrou
cantine quand il arrivait il ya quelques
années des acheteurs japonais sont venus
pour acquérir des chevaux percherons
parce qu'ils ont une tradition bien
particulière qui la course de très trac
c'est il ya des paris il ya vraiment des
cours très organisé il ya des fermes
d'état d'élevage il faut savoir que ces
chevaux japonais sont constituées entre
66 ans 10% de 200 de cheval cherchons la
notoriété du percheron a largement
dépassé les frontières de nogent le
rotrou et le musée de l'histoire du
perche lui rend un hommage mérité